Tom Curren the Patriots insider NBC
sports Boston of course was doing his
job as only Tom can after last night's
game I believe that he had a chance to
ask coach Bill Belichick about Antonio
Brown and what a lengthy exchange these
two had bill just wanted to see do you
have any comment on the reports and no
alrighty let's bring in Tom Curren well
done Tom thank you p.m. I actually did
follow up and finished it off with in
Antonio Brown after the process and an X
from them and I wish I was smarter and I
just finished it off with a I'm so no
comment on the impending Elvia noise
child nothing at all on that alright how
surprised are you that this happened not
not completely stunned no not not
shocked
they are looking for talent wherever
they can get it it's a position to need
they've done it before it's worked I'm
not surprised at all that it happened I
just I thought it might be a bridge too
far I started to look at some of the
little links like oh you know he just
almost attacked mike Mayock and SARS I
know Bill and Mike friends but all's
fair in love football and more I guess
how does this work very simply they
bring him in they say be on time do what
everybody else does it won't be that
hard and then see if he can conform and
how long he can conform but I do think
that they have very much a will see how
it goes
approach they're not going to bend the
way the Raiders did because they're not
in it for as much as the Raiders were do
they have any say on social media to the
Patriots tell their players you know
anything you do we want to see or you
know are they that draconian I think
they ought to be with him they certainly
aren't right now I mean Brady you and
Edelman and Vannoy I mean on down the
line
these guys have much bigger social media
presences
you would have ever thought Belichick
would have allowed five years ago they
comment they go back and forth with
people they argue with people some of
them not all of them certainly a
minority could probably compare it to
most teams but you know in the case of
Antonio Brown that seems to be where at
least 70% of his stuff emanates in terms
of driving teams crazy and saying things
to create issues so if I were the
Patriots I'd say whatever you say on
social media you can just pretend you're
saying it directly to Bill Belichick
it's like pretend your grandmother's in
the room yeah yeah yeah as far as the
identity of this team because I'm always
fascinated with the Patriots like who
are they this year or what are they this
year felt like they were maybe more of a
defensive heavy team certainly that
secondaries wonderful but did they just
become an offensive team with this
addition they were going to be a
defensive heavy team and a running team
like they were last year because of the
decline of Rob Gronkowski I think in
certainly his absence this year but
you've just lost the Hall of Fame player
who had one of his worst statistical
seasons and replaced him with the Hall
of Fame level player who is still in his
prime and it hasn't suffered any injury
so I think you can almost scrap all of
those expectations additionally within
the last month they've reacted Josh
Gordon who we didn't have any idea
whether he'd be back in the first half
of the season or not so this has gone
from a team with really just Julian
Edelman and Phillip Dorsett in no tight
end to a team with Josh Gordon Julian
Edelman Antonio Brown all in an offense
it already has a really good running
game so they're gonna be a pain in the
ass yes yes they are how how did they
deal with who gets touches there you
know because I think that that would be
my concern with Antonio Brown he's so
used to getting the ball he's used to
saying something to his quarterback but
now you have the Patriots with Belichick
and Brady I don't know if they even
allow that conversation like if Brown
comes back to the huddle and says
something to Brady like hey
I'm open like how does that conversation
go it'll be interesting to see whether
he does the nice soft kind Brady voice
or the shut the bleep up I'll tell you
when you're open I know you don't
what will also be interesting and I
spent a lot of time talking to the
Pittsburgh writers last night we've
covered them was to hear how imprecise
he is in the way he runs his routes you
know Jerry du Lac Ron cook mark Coppola
all guys have been there Jeremy Fowler
all of them to a man said that he pays
no attention to exactly what's drawn up
he does it by feel and part of that is
the reason why you see you saw so often
Ben Roethlisberger pump and pump it Pump
because he didn't know we're in Antonio
Brown was going to be Brady it's not a
pumper so he's either gonna be where
he's supposed to be or he's not going to
get the ball but he's averaged and
targets a game every year of his career
and there's games where that's not going
to happen here so it'll be fascinating
to see if he can deal with that and the
impact it will have on the a b84 brand
I know it's skewing negative but I think
it's also the reality who's more likely
to last the entire season there Josh
Gordon ur Antonio Brown that is skewing
negative I mean I think all of us would
agree that if we had put our chips on
one guy or the other that we prefer to
see I think I would prefer to see Josh
Gordon and I think it would I think I
would bet on Josh Gordon it's a lot the
board and at the current house is
Antonio Brown going to be in uniform
will he play against the Miami Dolphins
next weekend I would these are like
magic 8-ball questions science point to
yes but you know I spoke to somebody you
know or just communicated with someone
last night and they said you know we'll
begin to find out tomorrow meaning today
meaning Monday as to just how quickly he
can assimilate how he looks in practice
but I guarantee you you know it's
honeymoon period first day of school
stuff kitten couldn't be happier tail
Waggin it's going to be a great week for
Antonio Brown as a patriot I guarantee
it well [ __ ]
back home and his high school is you
know a half hour away from that Stadium
there so I would hate to break his heart
but bill I have family all right okay
we'll get you the bond an old softie
bill is there any other drama up there
New England just the fact that Brady is
now officially into a contract here with
and that's what's really fascinating
about a Antonio Brown see I've said all
the way through after he got his
contract what's going to happen is
Brady's going to have an Austin testicle
year he's gonna go to the table with
them in February or March or maybe even
January and they're going to say look
Tom we gave you 23 last year and your
numbers have dropped you're gonna be 43
next year we're not going to give you
more than 23 and that would be an
impetus for him to say you know what
then we're definitely going to go and
see what other teams have to say not
that he's gonna leave but he would do
that now his numbers could certainly
conceivably go up from where they were
last year which were good but not normal
Brady off-the-charts stuff so he might
have a very very good statistical year
as good as anybody I mean he certainly
started that way so it'll be fascinating
to see how Antonio browser presence
changes that conversation with the team
what about Grunk I know that is it more
enticing
more of a reality possibility with Josh
Gordon and a be there on that offense
that it's a great question from everyone
I've talked to close to the situation he
has absolutely no intention of returning
to the NFL and every time he intimates
it it's just to sell something else
which is his right good built his brand
he's gonna leverage it but from
everything I've been told there will be
no Rob Gronkowski in Foxborough this
year probably ever will keep it aside
from know he was there last night
there'll be no him in uniform how's that
keep asking those tough questions to
coach Belichick we appreciate it doing
my job I know you that's what you're
supposed to do that's the patriot way
Tom thank you that's Tom Curren Patriots
insider NBC Sports Boston for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
two
39 on DirecTV stream for free on BR live
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]